[Musik]
ich bin kommandant eines datenfunk
trupps beim start am 3 und was wir
meinen dienst in der kaserne ob man die
aufgaben der sportler und 3 sind die
sicherstellung der führungsunterstützung
maßnahmen die verpflegt und sanitäts
maßnahmen die instandsetzung und den
nachschub und transportaufgaben
[Musik]
das system aus dem wir heute datenfunk
stelle betreiben ist die schnittstelle
zwischen das telefon im büro und dem
funkgerät von der soldaten gefechtsfeld
[Musik]
als sanitätsoffizier sind zuständig für
die sanitätsdienstliche versorgung und
die erste hilfe ausbildung
[Musik]
nach der erstversorgung übergebe ich den
verletzten an das team des andenkens die
ihn so schnell wie möglich das nächste
feld verbringt
zu den fahrzeugen april
[Musik]
in eine funktion ist transport krippen
kommandant die funktion des gruppen
kommandanten beinhaltet die planung von
transporten für gefechts übungen oder
scharf schießen
die einteilung der fahrzeuge und der
kraftfahrer und eben auch die
durchführung der transporte
[Musik]
a
wir üben auch regelmäßig den abtransport
von schweren fahrzeugen
wenn das fahrzeug aufgeladen wurde
bringen wir das fahrzeug zur werkstatt
wird das abgeladen die werkstatt macht
er die erste sichtung und dann
entscheidet die werkstatt ob es vor ort
repariert wird oder in einer anderen
werkstatt verbracht wird
[Musik]
wir üben das gelände fahren auf unserer
gelände fahrstrecke am übungsplatz
da gibt es verschiedene steigungen und
gefällen zu absolvieren hat gibt sehr
fordernde steigungen wo man dann nur den
himmel sitzt und dann eben die fälle wo
man dann nur wer den boden sind und dann
geht s herunter
[Musik]